foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire update video in
this video I want to go over all the new
information revealed by George R Martin
on his not a Blog website only a few
hours ago George RR Martin not only
confirmed the Duncan egg series was
greenlit by HBO but he also revealed
some very interesting information about
HBO's other Game of Thrones successor
shows as well I think this is one of the
best updates he's given in months
because it does shed a light on a lot of
things the fandom has been wondering now
let's have a look at his not a Blog
website so you can see exactly what he
had to say he said the news is all over
the Internet by now the announcement was
made a few days ago at Warner media's
big event for the rollout and rebranding
of their new streaming service Max
formerly known as HBO Max which is
heading your way near the end of May I
was sworn to secrecy until then but now
that the word is out I can go ahead and
confirm it yes it's true there's another
successor show on its way Duncan egg are
coming to HBO The Working title will be
at night of the Seven Kingdoms the Hedge
Knight whether that will be the final
title I cannot say for sure Beyond
saying that no it won't be called Tales
of Duncan egg or the adventures of
Duncan egg or dunk an egg or anything
along those lines now I love Duncan Egg
and I know that fans refer to my
novellas as the duck and egg story sure
but there are millions of fans out there
who do not know these stories and the
title needs to Intrigue them too if you
don't know the characters Duncan egg
sounds like a sitcom something like
Laverne and Shirley Abbott and Costello
or Beavis and Butthead so no we want to
make sure Knight is in the title
Knighthood in Chivalry are Central to
the themes of these stories now aside
from the title what else can I say well
not a lot HBO has given us a green light
to film for a full season not only a
pilot episode most likely of six
episodes though that is not set in stone
and won't be until considerably later in
the developmental phase as most of you
know I have written and released three
novellas about Duncan egg the Hedge
Knight the Sworn Sword and the Mystery
Knight each of them initially released
independently in various anthologies
before being collected together in a
night of the Seven Kingdoms therefore if
any of you want to read all of George R
Martin's novellas about Duncan egg all
you have to do is buy or read a night of
the Seven Kingdoms because they're all
there inside now the first season will
be an adaptation of the first of the
three novellas the Hedge Knight the
story of how duck and egg first met
during a tournament at the Ashford
Meadow now the pilot episode is already
written and I think it's terrific it was
written by Ira Parker who is no stranger
to Westeros he was actually on Ryan
condo's writing staff for the first
season of House of the dragon and he
wrote the fourth episode of House of the
dragon's first season the king of the
narrow sea that's the episode where
Damon arrives back in King's Landing
after Conquering the stepstones and him
and ranera go down into the back alleys
of flea bottom Ryan condo is on board as
well well as an executive producer and
so am I now there is no set date as to
when the series will release or even for
the show to begin shooting but the
writing is already well underway IRA has
assembled a small but very talented team
and they're already at it building on
the foundations laid down last year and
our other creative Summits and of course
on the original Novella the Duncan egg
novellas are fully fleshed out
narratives more like the novels of A
Song of Ice and Fire than the imaginary
history of Fire and Blood those stories
are right there and our goal is to
create faithful adaptations to those
tales for the screen now this is really
great news because what he means is
Duncan egg has an actual story that's
written whereas House of the Dragon is
based on footnotes of second day and
third hand accounts now if the Hedge
Knight turns out as well as we hope it
will our hope would be to go one and
adapt the Sworn Sword in the mystery
Knight as well that will take a few
years then comes the hard part before we
reach the end of the novellas I will
need to find time to write all the the
other Duncan egg novellas that I always
wanted to and let's just say that
there's more of them than I had once
thought there's the Village Hero and the
Winterfell story that's the one that has
the She Wolves and maybe I need to write
that dornish adventure to slip in
between the Hedge Knight and the Sworn
Sword and after that there's more I just
need to finish the Winds of Winter and
then do either a dream of spring or
another volume of Fire and Blood then
slip in a new Duncan egg between each of
those and my copious spare time and that
will keep me ahead of Ira and his merry
crew for a few more years but I will
worry about that tomorrow today we're
celebrating Duncan egg are coming
alright folks now this is what makes me
very nervous as a fan as you can see
George R Martin is saying he's not done
writing the Duncan egg novellas which
means he doesn't have the ending he says
he hopes he's going to be able to write
more of them before the Duncan egg show
is over what that means is as of right
now the show will be in the same boat as
Game of Thrones was when Dan and Day
first started making that series and we
all remember how that ended George RR
Martin still hasn't finished writing a
song of ice and fire therefore Dan and
Dave had to basically write their own
ending to finish the show now thankfully
the Duncan egg novellas are much easier
to write because they're much shorter
however George will still need to find
the time to do them while he should be
finishing the Winds of Winter and a
dream of spring all I'm saying is this
might get messy because he will
eventually have to decide what he wants
to finish first for years now he said he
doesn't want to do any other jobs before
he finishes the ones of winter but it
doesn't sound like that's the only thing
on his mind I'm sure he doesn't want the
duck and egg show to run into the same
issues as Game of Thrones and I would
guarantee HBO doesn't want that either I
just hope he's able to finish the ones
of winter before he's in a spot where he
has to decide to set it on a back burner
because there's other shows that need
him more this is something I will
definitely keep my eyes on moving
forward and as always I will let you
know what's happening behind the scenes
as soon as I know myself with that in
mind make sure you subscribe now let me
get back to what he said on the not a
Blog he goes on to say way back in the
summer of 2016 when HBO first started
thinking about the Game of Thrones
spin-offs I went to them with two ideas
the dance of the Dragons which in due
time became House of the dragon and
Duncan egg that was seven years ago and
I can hardly believe it myself the
lesson here is that development takes
time I see all these stories on the
internet about other shows being killed
or abandoned no idea where they get this
stuff and it just makes me shake my head
the show about nymeria is still in
development and so is the sea snake show
we just had a great week on that one
working with the writers and there's
others live action and animated by
others he means the shows about aegon
and Jon Snow how many will get the green
light like Duncan egg it's hard to say
how long will it take well that depends
no one knows for sure when I was in
grade school there was a cop show that
ended every week with there are 8
million stories in the Naked City this
has been one of them in and that was
only in New York City Westeros and essos
are a lot bigger with even more stories
we just need the time to tell them so as
you can see he ends the not a Blog on a
very hopeful note not only are they
working on House of the dragon and dunk
an egg but they're still developing the
shows about nymeria the sea snake and
many many more now if you're only a fan
of the shows this is obviously amazing
news but if you only care about the wins
of winter or a dream of spring well this
might have you a little concerned he
obviously cannot focus on those as much
when he's working on so many other ideas
now the great news is it doesn't look
like Game of Thrones is leaving our
televisions anytime soon I don't know
about all of you but I'm very excited
for the future of the Game of Thrones
Cinematic Universe lately our little
fandom is getting a hell of a lot more
exciting let me know what all of you
think about the new information down
below give me your thoughts on
everything are you worried that Duncan
egg isn't finished do you think it will
run into the same issues as Game of
Thrones how many of you actually think
George Martin will finish the wins of
winter or will HBO have him writing all
this other stuff for the shows also what
other shows do you want to see get made
next leave it all down below once again
I have to thank all of you for watching
the videos I really appreciate it I hope
you all have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
foreign
[Music]